[Music]
if you've been here before you'll notice
something cropping up time and time
again
hot thermal waters powering hungary's
age-old love of spas
a love that can be traced back thousands
of years a history that can still be
seen today
hungary has a unique geology that allows
deep thermal waters heated by the
earth's mantle to spring to the surface
it's no surprise to hear then that
hungarians have been making use of this
for thousands of years
but how did this obsession begin
well we might have to get dirty for this
let's start near the beginning
as i said look like
[Music]
now let's skip forward a few centuries
this is the turkish ruler spa it's built
in 1571.
we have six different bars called pool
with 11 degrees of celsius there's 30 a
33
a 36 and 42 degrees warm
it's a fantastic feeling to that at the
16th century the steam the warm the
lights and i think it's it's unique
and finally to a time that's more
familiar
long after the turkish area the sea
chinese bus was built in the 1918.
nowadays is one of the biggest bus
complex in europe
under hungary 75
is thermal water water comes very deep
from the earth more than 1 000 meter we
have a swimming pools and the thermapose
some voters they go for their lungs just
to smell it if you have some problem
relaxing here for three hours you will
feel
better and better
every bus has this have their own
character their own smells and their own
feelings it's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
you